I will put this man's body work up with
anybody else's we're talking big and
small screen platoon Wall Street Point
Break seven office space any given
Sunday scrubs the rock and we're not
even talking about his stage work which
I've personally seen in Glengarry Glen
Ross and then there's the stand against
evil original horror comedy series on
IFC season two finale airs tomorrow
night at 10:00 p.m. again on IFC Johnny
C McKinley love seeing you here brother
but you love getting out of the blocks
nice and quick but I'd like to stop for
a second I noticed before I came down
here just watching you in the garage big
I don't know 70 inch or in the garage
yeah you look so damn good right now
it's alright the facial hair is working
then you put the glasses on you look
Shawn like Sean Connery in Raiders you
look you have a whole thing going you're
defying gravity look at you you look
good I'm wearing the glasses and I've
got I've got the facial hair suit it
works that's all I can tell you all
right I'll take it
look you look young and firm is it is it
high-definition yeah of course it is
yeah are you watching your giant games
in there yeah okay
we'd like to lift on Sunday mornings
that we're out here what do we get to
ten o'clock start out here yes so you
know you do you clean up on Sunday you
know whatever muscle group you didn't
get earlier if they're surf we're not in
the garage but if there's not surf
everybody just comes over and while
you're wearing your stand against evil
t-shirt you're showing off the hockey
league right now no it's all about Stan
it's all about Stan yeah flight and
gravity that's what my father used to
say my father played for the he was a
two-time all-american you versus
Pennsylvania and and he stayed in shape
his whole life and people you'll see his
name was Jerry McKinley and people like
juror how do you how do you stay in
shape and say light and gravity jumbo
flight and gravity I heard fighting
gravity maybe ten thousand times and now
I finally know what he was talking about
flight and gravity fightin gravity I
don't know if you wear this because you
know I with my work of the NFL Network
John I have some insight that is also
the title of the 2017 New York Giants
and of your highlight film really it's
called ficus so what do we do what do we
do gravity as giant as
sycophants what do we do come January
what do we do I don't know your coach is
I think coaching for his gig right now I
think does Eli end up down with Tom
Coughlin and you get the kid from USC
what do you do is that too radical yes
no no I don't think it's too radical
that's the move do you have to extend
plays in the NFL with your feet now or
are you no longer relevant if you can't
do that I have to you have to here's and
here's what few people I mean Case
Keenum all of a sudden look he looks
fantastic look I swear you just watched
the neck pain expatriate game Brady's
doing the same thing now he's not
rolling out all right like you're seeing
all of these pockets being moved but he
is sidestepping the rush I'll take that
he has taken one or two steps to avoid
things that you would think a 40 year
old is not but I don't know what in the
hell happened I know everybody got hurt
and I know all that I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about in the new
NFL 2017 yes don't you have to be able
to extend plays with your feet yes I
agree with a kid in Minnesota but I
don't think Eli's the problem there do
you think that utilize the problem I
don't know I'm asking you you know one
hell of a lot more than I do
you've seen enough but I don't I don't
know first of all the Giants have no run
game zero I don't know what happened
there I think they thought that no more
problems was gonna be there guy that
line needs help they thought the kid
from what UCLA was gonna be their guy I
thought they thought he was gonna be a
guy and now you know they got this kid
Orleans dark or whatever but who is the
one Brotman who said this it was Bob
Ryan yesterday right that some coaches
or lieutenants and others are generals
threatened and he said McAdoo's
lieutenant that he's a lieutenant not a
general don't the Mehra's stick with
people forever they stick with people
through a season and so that's why I'm
saying that he's coaching for his job
that win against Kansas City
yeah was impressive it really I I know
that they haven't been playing well of
late but these are teams that they would
be blown out by in the first six weeks
of the season and I thought your segment
earlier
the the kid the tailback on Kansas City
I thought that breakdown was spot-on
you know yeah but it's not a giant hunt
is just not the same why I don't know
why either he's hit a rookie wall what
is a rookie wall well is that in
baseball where they scatter they finally
Scout you know your tendencies now no in
that that's one but two that in in in
college when you replace game seven game
eight you're you're towards the end of a
season oh but that in professional
football
you are just hit six you're right in the
middle and so or maybe he just read his
newspaper headlines and heard about him
on don't believe your clippings so and
now he's fighting gravity I used to use
the Jerry McKinley term but you know I
was a good Kansas City team the first
five games to I know it were world
beaters and Andy Reed of the Patriots
not sixteen and two in coming off a buys
in his career and they were coming off a
bye this past week and you're in your
g-men took care of it so I don't I think
McAdoo is coaching for his job and that
the team would if he has the last six
games of the year
well would be like 500 if he goes 500 is
a five win season that they don't have
one of those seasons where it's the
worst ever right in the history of the
team if they finished two and fourteen I
think he's done but he came out and he
said this week John in a meeting saying
that uh this is my dream job and I'm not
giving it up so join me and I like that
I know I like owning it and it worked
out I don't know we'll see what happens
Jhansi McKinley here on the Rich Eisen
show how about in your New York Jets do
they make the playoffs for a second
there there we're going to it they're
four and six and which in the new AFC
means you just might be your boy right
in it you're right in it I don't know
man this team I thought I don't I don't
know they can it would be the most jet
like thing to rip off five of their last
six you guys are ready to go one in 15
this year cuz I wanted one of these kids
playing college ball in this town I
looked at you even said the Giants maybe
they should send Eli PACA down Jax I'm
fielding input right now I don't
Oh something radical has to happen cuz
it's not working yeah I know I don't
know what I have no idea the Jets might
they might make it they may not I don't
know
well you would have you been following
the next two are you a Knick fan yeah
Johnny Mac and I John Mac granola and I
went to a Knicks game the other night in
the garden and they put us down on the
floor and I don't know when the last
time you went to a basketball game where
your feet are on the floor it's just
like hockey when you're next to the
glass it's a different experience yeah
because you get the size and the speed
of these modern athletes and it's
glorious and we watch the Knicks beat
the Nets and it was a it was the
beginning of a turnaround for the next
making them quasi irrelevant right and
so you're that you know you're right
near the owners right there right
McMackin rows seats are right we Olin no
no no no John was my guest Oh
these were Stan seats Jesus Danny was in
parasite Norfolk John Wow he was my
pilot fish I'm sorry
I mean dress store for stand against
evil the finest horror comedy on TV
right now
so IFC has some floor seats in Madison
no some people got to put Johnnie sheet
down them hit a little right down the
middle you don't want me in Johnny maxi
was it but I think I've asked you this
before but we're on the subject Knicks
and chicks that line from Wall Street is
that was that written was that in the
script no Chelsey's you came up with
that I'm gonna break you Henderson this
that was Johnny food I heard you just
went third person right there name
dropped and third burden that was an
ad-lib that buddy-buddy I've got I've
got Nixon checks and Knicks and you came
up with that one yes
what take did you come up with that one
I don't know I was doing talk radio at
night the play with Eric Bogosian and I
was doing Wall Street during the day for
about three weeks and so it's kind of a
New York actors dream and so I was we
were down towards the Woolworth Building
yeah which is a straight shot up to up
Lafayette to the public yeah and those
three weeks are about as good as it gets
for New York actors and so I was pretty
in other words if a boxer can be can be
ring ready actors can get on their toes
yes when they're doing Wall Street all
day and then talk radio at night you're
you're in pretty good acting shape if
there is such a thing sure and so when
somebody calls action all of a sudden
you can access maybe stuff that if you
weren't
in good acting shape that maybe it
wouldn't have been there and I was I was
rate I was on my toes on that set it
felt good and on on the set of Wall
Street yes which which actor or actress
that you've worked in in a scene has
kept you on your toes the most that you
knew I knew I'm I'm I need I'm getting
in there I'm getting in that ring when
we did Glengarry which you and Sue's
came to see when you're on stage with Al
Pacino you want to you want to be on
your toes because he can go anywhere
he's he's like a jazz player even with
Mamet's texts al is like a jazz player
and you you you want to get in in that
in that frequency with him cuz it's
pretty glorious if you can cuz I'd
imagine too cuz we talk about it all the
time with athletes like hey I don't want
to let I'm in a huddle with breeze I'm
gonna huddle with Brady I'm in a defense
with Ray Lewis I cannot not do my job I
cannot let this person I find that if
you can get in your own flow State
whether that's in sports or on stage at
the Schoenfeld where you guys came to
see Glengarry or on a set with Oliver if
you can get in your flow State yeah
it'll meld mm-hmm so is that you're
trying to piggyback someone else that's
hard cuz right that's hard do you know
where they going so if you can find a
flow State I talk to athletes about it
all the time and that that's where the
glorious stuff is like being in the zone
that's sort of thing yeah shrinks call
it the flow state and flow and which
which stone movie left you I guess spent
the most platoon by far why is that cuz
we were there doing a revolution and it
had been postponed for a year or two and
when we finally got there Marcos
wouldn't leave and they were 12 year
olds walking around Manila with ak-47s
and it was really scary it was real so
when somebody called action if you had
to act like you were scared you were you
didn't act it was spooky no kidding and
then because he shot and shot it in
sequence which is unheard of as the
characters died they left and so by the
end of the film there was about four of
us still standing and you know three
months later and there's four of you and
there's a revolution and a threatened
coup every Thursday yeah
we spent after that that was for real
that Oliver captured it all of that
would be for naught if the lens didn't
pick it up but Oliver picked it all up
Jhansi McKinley here on the Rich Eisen
show so let's talk stand against evil
you're really proud of this I cry I see
how much you tweet about it and what's
being written about it critics freaking
love this thing what's it been like for
you on IFC doing this show I've see put
as much slack in the leash as we want it
so the trade-off is we'll give you no
money to do this show but we'll give you
creative autonomy do you want to do it
and Dana Gould who created stand against
evil ran the writers room in The
Simpsons for about 10 years which is
unheard of and his whole time those 10
years he just wanted to do stand against
evil you want to be with that guy and so
we go down to Atlanta we shoot 8
episodes a year which is the new normal
in other words when doing scrubs it was
24 episodes a year but we do eight
episodes in four weeks in four days
which is preposterous but I have all the
actors rehearses like a play and we get
him down to Atlanta and we crank and the
show is off the charts the biggest hit
on IFC and tomorrow night's the finale
the first see the second season and it's
ridiculously ambitious and it all the 14
episodes we did before tomorrow night
yield at these two episode this two
episodes when I finale look good which
is so great it's so great everything we
took away from the first 14 just realize
fruition everything that everything we
wanted to do is in the the last two
episodes which is a nice thing to be
able to say 10:00 p.m. Eastern on IFC
again that's tomorrow night Wednesday
night before we let Johnny C ago you put
something on our Twitter handle
shortly before he stepped by the way on
our Callaway corner cutting surface in
jarred how many row did you job seven
and you asked these guy what's the
record here their records eight by which
five by the long way not the short way
that he was doing which guest had it
which guest made eight I have the record
oh yeah I guessed I guess it should be
staff guess well you tell you tell me
coconut guest
ah you tell me John I mean how should I
handle the fact that I have a member of
the staff subverting guests
accomplishment no the way I'm taking
this to is to have the record like
shouldn't they be working oh geez hello
poker tell Carrie Nason's questions or
in the case of Eric working on some
stats for just drawing you're just
rolling putts around after hours all
right go to get to the poll question
here okay great so Johnny you had some
fantastic slicked back hair as a head of
the LA Bureau and Point Break and kind
of got me thinking who wore it best
yeah you and Point Break or Ben McAdoo
in real life or who inspired who join
great points we did that a few years ago
yeah while ago maybe he is channeling
you John
maybe so I get broad shoulders Ben can
jump on board I'm a family man I can
carry the load if Ben and the chi men
need to get on these I'm fighting
gravity let's go what are people saying
it's it's Johnny C right he's where he's
crushing this this I think so yeah i
don't know i don't think it's picked up
much steam yet i just thought it was
hilarious it's true it's true john loved
having here's thanks love being here
thank you the best say hi to your lovely
wife Nicole and your enjoy your
Thanksgiving holiday come back don't be
small about the gravy please do that oh
is that right oh really you're good I'd
pour it over myself why why do I'm not
appropriate it's the good whatabout pie
what's your best pie I'm not pie guy I
told you I'm the gravy guy Wow
yeah you can be both by the way he only
puts whatever food you can put a sermon
a boat that's it a courser pine a boat
correct right I'm a gravy guy yeah and
try don't think you can put stuffing in
a boat you put gravy in a boat find a
boat doesn't work bingo stand against
evil on IFC 10:00 p.m. Eastern on IFC
tomorrow night the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience